well a man described as having a violent
criminal history is on the run and
authorities believe he could be here in
southern Nevada and tonight our series
Manhunt Monday continues 8 news now
investigator Vanessa Murphy shows you
why this fugitive may be easy to
recognize
Theodore Lee may be easy to recognize
thanks to this Inc the convicted felon
is wanted by the U.S Marshals he's not a
good dude all around he's
armed and dangerous with violent
tendencies it's only a matter of time
before something else happens if he's
not safely taken into custody
supervisory Deputy U.S Marshal Ray
Venegas is part of a team searching for
Lee it's supposed to be associated with
Asian gangs the 36 year old has been on
the run for more than three years here's
how this happened according to court
records we obtained in 2010 Lee was
convicted for having a gun while dealing
drugs and for having a weapon in the
first place since he was prohibited as
an already convicted felon he received a
nine-year sentence credit for time
already served followed by five years of
supervised release in 2019 he was
accused of violating those terms because
of an arrest prosecutors say he stabbed
a nightclub bouncer in the face kidney
and leg Lee skipped a court date in
April of 2020 that was all in the state
of Virginia and now the U.S Marshals say
he's likely in the Las Vegas guess area
we're pretty concerned because he's been
wanted for a while he knows he's been
wanted Venegas says people close to him
know too the U.S Marshals are asking for
the Public's help to find Lee they say
if you see him calling a tip but don't
approach him they also say he's likely
in east Las Vegas or Henderson and could
be working as a tattoo artist Vanessa
Murphy 8 News Now